in 2019 senator pitchet took home a
compensation of
281 million dollars or a little over a
quarter billion dollars there are of
course people like elon musk and ray
dalio that blow that number out of the
water
the one key difference between these top
earners and sunder however is that
sunder didn't found his own company or
hedge fund in fact sunder did not join
google until 2004 and when he did join
he was simply a manager
moreover sunder did not have any high
level connections or very much money
when he came to the us
sunder quite literally started at the
very bottom and worked his way up the
corporate ladder to the very top
so here's us on their pitch it became
the number one paid employee in the
world starting with nothing
taking a look back sunderer was born on
june 10th 1972 in chennai india
his father was an electrical engineer
and his mother was a stenographer
it doesn't seem like the family had any
financial problems per se but they
weren't rich by any means the family
lived in a small two-room apartment and
sunder and his brother would sleep in
the living room though sunday's
background wasn't particularly helpful
for him his intellect would prove
extremely helpful from a very young age
sunderer was extremely bright with one
of his most notable characteristics
being his insane memory
apparently sunder was able to recall
every single number he ever dialed on
their home rotary phone considering this
it's not too surprising that sunder
would end up attending the indian
institute of technology or iit where he
studied metallurgical engineering
after iit sunder scored a spot at
stanford where he got a masters in
engineering and material science he
didn't stop right there either sunder
turned around and tried to get a phd
from stanford but he soon decided that
gaining work experience was probably the
better bet
so he dropped out of his doctoral
program and got a job at applied
materials as an engineer slash product
manager in the late 1990s he didn't
stick around at applied materials for
too long though as he quickly shifted
over to mckenzie and the company
around the same time swinter decided
that getting an mba would further propel
his career so he would end up attending
the wharton school of business and
securing an mba
a few years later in 2004 sunder would
attend an interview at google on april
fools day
ironically before applying to google
himself sunder had convinced one of his
friends to not apply at google this was
during the height of the dotcom crash
where over 90 of internet companies went
to bankrupt so sunder's warning made
sense yet he ironically ended up
applying himself his interview actually
took place on the day that google
launched gmail and given that it was
april fool's day like many swinder
thought that gmail was just a joke
anyway sunder of course got the job and
he started working as a product manager
overlooking google search toolbar
development a lot of us don't even
remember that google used to have such a
toolbar but at the time this was
actually a major development you see
just two years later in 2006 microsoft
made being the default search engine on
internet explorer however since many
google users had the google search
toolbar installed google was able to
heavily reduce the effects of
microsoft's decision
so by chance sunderer found himself
working on one of the most important
developments for google at the time
aside from playing a key role in the
young company this experience made soon
to realize how dependent google was on
microsoft if microsoft had made this
decision a few years ago google may not
have become so popular in the first
place so in an effort to minimize risk
moving forward sunder would suggest
creating a browser
most of the managers and executives
above him didn't really like this idea
sure having a popular browser would give
google a major upper hand
but it seemed like it was simply way too
late to enter the browser game
internet explorer had literally come out
over a decade ago and even safari and
firefox had been out for multiple years
so much of google's management didn't
think that developing a browser was a
viable idea two guys however were
willing to encourage the idea and this
was of course google's founders larry
page and sergey brin
larry and sergey knew that google
success had never come from being first
they were eight years late to search
engines and they were actually 33 years
late to the email scene
in fact when they bought youtube they
didn't even buy their earliest video
sharing platform
the first video sharing platform called
shareyourworld.com came out in 1997
while youtube wasn't even launched till
2005. so clearly google was never the
first one on the scene
yet given google success it was clear to
larry and sergey that being first did
not necessarily determine the success of
a product or service so larry and sergey
encouraged sunder to give the browser a
shot sunder and his team would develop
google chrome over the next few years
with a few key targets the first target
was creating an unbeatable ui
google had already built up a name for
being the cool kid on the block they
offered more storage more services and a
better user experience than any of their
competition
so chrome had to live up to these
customer expectations fortunately for
sunder this wasn't too difficult as
internet explorer was pretty clunky at
the time
the ui wasn't sunday's only focus though
he knew that in order to attain
long-term sustained success chrome had
to be a developer favorite instead of
trying to guess what web developers
liked sunder decided to let developers
show him what they liked through
chromium chromium is an open source web
browser that was launched in september
of 2008. this allows under his team to
easily implement input from developers
from around the world and as you would
guess this made google chrome extremely
stable and fast combine this with a far
superior ui and switching to chrome was
a no-brainer for most people despite the
successful launch of chrome sunder never
limited himself to just one project in
the background he was also laying the
foundation for other fundamental
projects one of these endeavors was
google drive
google had already stepped into the
office product space in 2006 with the
launch of google docs google sheets and
google slides while these products
weren't nearly as robust as microsoft's
offerings they were completely free
which attracted a large number of casual
users in 2010 google acquired a company
called dockverse which allowed multiple
people to collaborate on documents while
this was an intriguing idea the
implementational wasn't quite right
sunder however had the perfect solution
for this google drive
instead of storing files locally google
drive allowed users to store their files
on google's data centers which not only
made it easy to collaborate but also
easy to access these files anywhere in
the world similar to google chrome
sunder did not invent the cloud by any
means however his execution was
brilliant and that brings us into his
third biggest contribution which was
chrome os
once again chrome os was also not an
original idea
in fact larry ellison the founder of
oracle was trying to create something
similar in the late 1990s called the
network computer
but larry found it extremely difficult
to gain much attraction from the market
as he was simply targeting all pc users
who wanted a cheaper machine
sunder however targeted a super niche
market students and light users chrome
os didn't try to compete against windows
or mac
there's no question that windows and mac
are far better for serious tasks but
this is actually chromebook's biggest
strength by just focusing on simple
computer tasks and leaving the serious
tasks up to windows and mac chrome os
was able to nail the simple tasks for an
unbeatable price and this has proven
extremely attractive to a niche group of
customers given all of these major
contributions to google it's not
surprising that sunder was promoted to
senior vice president of chrome and apps
in 2012. just a year later in 2013 andy
rubin the creator of android would leave
google
and larry page would give center pitcher
the responsibility of managing the
android division as well
one of swinder's biggest contributions
with android was android one which
significantly drove down the cost of
entry-level smartphones cinder also made
android a much more integrated part of
google before center took over android
android basically operated as a separate
business that was simply owned by google
sunder's influence at google would
slowly but consistently increased year
after year and in october of 2014 he was
promoted to product chief while this is
quite a significant position many other
tech companies were offering sunder even
higher level positions there were some
rumors floating around that twitter was
trying to hire sunder as ceo in 2015. it
also seems like microsoft was seriously
considering hiring sunder as ceo in 2014
despite these attractive offers sunder
decided to stick to google and this
would eventually pay off massively in
august of 2015 larry page and sergey
brin decided to step back from google
they created a new holding company
called alphabet and they became the
leaders of alphabet meanwhile sunder was
promoted to ceo of google at this point
he was basically the ceo of the entire
company and larry and sergey basically
played chairman roles but this would
become official at the end of 2019 as
larry and sergey stepped down from
alphabet as well promoting sunder to ceo
of alphabet
and given that google stock has grown
over 260 percent over the past five
years it's not surprising that sunder
has received such massive compensation
so what can we learn about cinder's
unstoppable rise to the top
well the key thing to note about sunder
is that he is not particularly notable
within any of the classic character
traits he's not an innovative genius
like elon musk or steve jobs nor is he a
creative genius like steven spielberg or
james cameron he also wasn't just at the
right place at the right time like steve
ballmer
and though sunder is extremely
intelligent i don't necessarily think
his success can be attributed to his
intelligence either
after all it's not like he's developing
rocket engines or personally developing
self-driving cars
but despite not sticking out in any one
of these categories sunder has achieved
phenomenal success and i think that can
be attributed to one thing unparalleled
execution he didn't create browsers or
the cloud or smartphones or even a
company for that matter however sunder
was able to bring every product he
worked on to life better than any of the
competition whether that be through the
ui the cosplay customer or the
integration with the google's other
products sunder has proven that you
don't have to be first to be the best
and given that this was basically the
foundation for google as a whole
i can't think of anyone better than
sunder piche to leave the company
why do you guys think sunder is so
successful comment that down below
also drop a like if you think sunder
deserves his success
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]